heute ist der tag gekommen meine damen
und herren wir alle haben sehr lange
darauf gewartet leute waren da für leute
waren dagegen allerdings attestiert
einmal die mehrheit der gebäude welche
mittel eingeblendet ich gebe auf und das
ist auch der sünde heutigen video ever
bei der tv-serie ich habe teil eins
schon mal hochgeladen auf meinem kanal
und ich würde sagen ich durch direkt auf
play es geht darum dass ich dieser
kleine typ hier bin und muss an dieses
tor hier im rhein kommen darin bin ich
jetzt war die nächsten level das würden
beispielsweise fallen wenn ich in welche
fallen reinlaufen schätze ich und ich
hab auch hier schon gesehen hier
beispielsweise eine unsichtbare wand
die erscheint dann nur kurzzeitig oder
so hier springt rüber und dann hier
pretty cool locker und ich bin schon
abgerechnet ob besser über die
hindernisse drüber und hier mit einem
doppelsprung mein gott was ist denn das
da oben kommen den bach runter hier auf
das hindernis braucht dann hier in
doppelsprung hier schnell warum ich habe
halt auch die möglichkeit unten auf
diesen button zu drücken und dann bin
ich quasi um ein dorf waren die leute
schlafen dann gebe ich quasi auf und
habe okay okay jetzt habe ich die chance
meine okay okay noch mal von vorne beim
drücken des knopfes heißen dass ich
aufgebe und sage dass ich nicht weiter
schaffe aber wir haben hier schon das
letzte level 6 in der wärme gab
geschafft mal ganz langsam ihr luca hier
werde ich jetzt von laserkanonen
abgeschossen und es ist für alle gleich
level die vorhin flossen nur dass ich
jetzt noch laserkanone ja mein gott
trotzdem ist jetzt komplett in grün
alles okay okay etr nicht schon genug
dass ich irgendwie hier von den blauen
abgezogen werden einvernommen grünen
dazu ist auch in ordnung kommt leute mir
das schaffe ich jetzt hier zu hoch und
mio
dame auch schon den achten vor geschafft
ich weiß nicht was diese plattform labor
mein gott auf hey hier vorne plattform
das heißt ich werde auf die plattform
schavan ich muss anscheinend erst auf
die plattform händen entsteht vor allem
ich habe er 20 prozent geschafft wie
soll ich lasse ihn hinkriegen meine
damen und herren alter 20 prozent der
würfe dürfte er wird auf jeden fall fakt
dass ich etwas vor dem grünen laser
weglaufen mutter ich will nicht sagen
ich gebe auf aber ich probiere es mal
hier noch weiter so okay doch dieser
seite hier auf die mauer die mauer auf
die laufstrecke verbindet ganz geschafft
ob er wieder auf die mauer
warum denn die ganze 2 conny bescheid in
motion verliert darüber mit dem ok
springe ich da oben gegen wahrscheinlich
gefällt der ganzes green road oder habe
auf die mauer also ich bin auf der mauer
mein gott op kommt eine ewigkeit später
hier genügend warten jetzt auf die marke
ist so fucking schwierig mit dieser
ungenauen steuerung irgendwas auch nur
ansatzweise geschnitten wirklich also
hier ab ob die mauer
doch noch 40 mal auf die mauer und hier
auch die pentax mal überlaufen dann
hierhin hiermit den abwarten diesem es
tut mir leid weil sich in dem video
nicht ganz so kraft schneide wie ich die
anderen videos immer gemacht habe
allerdings muss ich in zwei stunden
blieb in 2 stunden nach berlin fliegen
und ich schneide diese video hier
wahrscheinlich gerade im flugzeug
gewartet ego sie uns jetzt nicht ohne
leute ich weiß es gibt locker videos bei
youtube wo irgendwer es hinkriegt ja
okay dass ich nicht mit dem grünen laser
gerade wurst ging dahin trägt das ganze
ding hundertprozentig durchzuspielen
aber eher wie krank müssen diese leute
mir scheiß egal ob ich das hinkriege
oder nicht wie soll man denn überhaupt
hinkriegen wenn man schaffen will genau
bin auf der plattform wenn wir draußen
springe rüber über die bunt
es steht also wie soll ich das wenn ihr
zufrieden ich bin auf jeden fall erdmann
auf dieser seite wartet ja den blauen
laser ablaufen um hierüber an die wand
wir dran oh mein gott nein aber es
wieder eine band ok ok städten rückstau
mein gott ich habe keine große zeit bei
einem 50 minuten flug in langes video zu
schneiden deswegen gebe ich mir jetzt
noch eine minute uncut und versuche es
an der zeit hinzukriegen hier rüber hier
lang und jetzt bin ich auf dieser seite
warte hier den fall ab und laub wird dir
über bin an der wand und springe über
bin ein alter familienvater wieder von
freundlich aber nur eine minute an
kapital bin auf dieser seite war sich
nie wieder den grünen laser ablaufe
zurück an die wand auf der plattform
hier oben bin hier oben dass ich genau
in der luft von ibiza abgeschossen
werden doch wenn wir auf dieser seite
genau da wenn ich ankomme okay dann
kommen direkten laser bin auf dieser
seite wieder drücken wir widmen den ok
ich bin wieder abgeschossen worden essl
ordnung alter mittlerweile wisse leute
mittlerweile vielleicht ein bisschen
scheißegal
doch ich will wieder an der wand
springen gutes gefühl die leute bin hier
um mein gott
auf der letzten platform a fucking kenia
auf der letzten plattform leute ist es
ein perfekter ernst genau wieder eher
wenig springe genau dann schiebt der
laser bringe wieder ihre beiden immer
wieder meine alt bewährte taktik warte
hier mitten abspringe hoch jetzt an die
wand okay vielleicht mein letzter schrei
genau weil da